[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome into the dark horse podcast live
stream q a
78 may 1st 2021
right did i get all that right yeah you
did that was a lot of information
oh i should say i forgot i should have
announced during the main podcast
that we have a new dark horse discussion
up with me
and jamie wheel and so if you haven't
checked it out you should check it out i
i just slipped my mind that we had
another announcement so
jamie's new book is out is that right
jamie's new book is out
recapture the rapture and that's not the
only clever turn of
phrase in the book actually it's not no
so i have not listened to your
conversation with jamie yet but he's
terrific
uh we became friends with him a few
years ago and his uh
his first book co-authored with stephen
cutler is stealing fire
yep is that right um it's excellent
is that really the right is that the
right title do i have it right um
yes i think that's right anyway it's
excellent uh i imagine this next one is
too
so it's good you got to get past his
thick texas accent
but once you do it's awesome
no he does not well some kind of accent
i
i assumed it was texas because that's
what i was talking to him really
okay and for those of you who are
concerned um the other two cats do still
exist we just decided not to tell them
about the cream this week because
um one of them was not having an easy
time digesting it so
that's what's going on behind us one
very pleased fairfax
yes first we're going to start with
three questions from last week
move into questions from the discord
server and then jump into questions from
this week
one do you see any opportunities to
apply evolutionary processes to areas or
problems not generally addressed in that
way
for instance ai education business
government policy etc
do you see any obvious low-hanging fruit
uh
yes it's all over the place it's
everywhere right problem is convincing
people that it is but yeah um the fact
that and this is a lot of what we do
right like i mean
frankly this is the vaccinologists and
virologists going like you don't have
any expertise you're evolutionary
biologists like
dudes if you don't understand that
viruses evolve we got a problem here yep
and we do have exactly that problem
apparently yes yeah yeah i know the the
low hanging fruit is all over the place
um
you know it takes a certain amount of
getting used to you have to learn to
think this way but
um you know in essence
the vaccine and covet evolution question
comes down to you want to create
an unjumpable evolutionary gap you want
to create an
obstacle so difficult that evolution
cannot cross it
and instead what we seem to be doing is
creating
an easy jump creating small enough steps
that selection can figure their way
across them
and you know if only we could make that
point simply so that
we didn't endlessly run into this uh
sort of uh utopian thinking about
solutions
and you have actually explicitly made
this argument with regard to ai
an analogous argument anyway ai and i've
also made it in
the context of fourth frontier
solutions for governance which is that
you don't you don't want to give
the corrupting influences a training
course on how to corrupt better you want
to give them
a situation in which the attempt to
corrupt the system
is ruinous and it's such a big setback
that those who engage in it do not end
up ahead but behind
yep and discussion of fourth frontier
comprises the final chapter of
our book which will be out in a few
months
okay next question why is childbirth
painful and dangerous
walking upright bigheads farming
revolution question mark
how will it evolve considering diets
best regards from finland you would love
it here consider
visiting one day so there's sort of
three hypotheses three possibilities
proposed here walking upright big heads
farming revolution
i don't think agricultural revolution
has anything
you know made things worse with regard
to childbirth
with the possible caveat that
um if women are less active certainly
not being not being as
fit makes childbirth more dangerous but
the first two things here
the becoming bipedal um you know that
that move from being quadripedal to
bipedal and changing hip shape in order
to become stable
and not not and women not having such
wide hips that they become
unstable in combination with
large heads as a result of our big
brains which is a big
part of what makes humans human that
combination
is is the thing that is usually
described as why child birth and humans
is so much different and harder and more
dangerous than it is for
everyone else really so i'm surprised to
hear you say you don't think
uh the agricultural revolution or at
least
the um abundance
of food has made things worse because it
seems you think babies are bigger
yeah i think they're going to be less
scrawny but heads aren't fatter
i've run into some fatheads in my day
and i know we say that but it's not
actually what we mean right
and i mean it's possible that heads um
are also getting bigger but you know
the less scrawny babies and and
and longer babies won't make birth more
difficult it really is
head diameter yeah head diameter which
is why birth has been moved earlier in
the developmental sequence incidentally
actually bob trivers tweeted yesterday a
new result
and i can't remember um maybe while
you're answering something i'll figure
out i can't remember what species it was
in
um but that found evidence um for uh
genomic imprinting in which maternally
derived genes
cause gestation to be shorter and
paternally derived genes paternally
imprinted genes
um cause gestation to be longer so you
have so
for for everyone uh rather than us
having this private conversation here
um following from david hague's seminal
work in the 1990s
um the idea that genes are able to
keep track of what parent they came from
and will have
different incentives in terms of things
like fetal growth depending on whether
or not they came from the mother
who is um interested in the survival and
success of her baby but also in the
survival and success of future babies
or if those genes those alleles came
from the father
who in a non-monogamous species at least
is unlikely to have any future kids with
the with that mother
and so has only an interest in the
maximum survival and success of that
individual and not in the future
reproductive output of
um of the mother so the idea the
prediction then
was that um that maternally imprinted
genes maternally derived genes in
fetuses
would push towards smaller birth weights
and shorter gestation times and such
and the paternally imprinted or derived
genes would push towards higher birth
rates and
and longer gestation times and there's a
piece of empirical research that uh
that finds this that's amazing i did not
catch that tweet nor did i see that
research
yet i will say you just blew right by
that awesome argument in favor of
monogamy one of my favorite arguments
in favor of my favorite breeding system
of all time
i mean it's just saying that because i'm
sitting here um
i'm saying that because i found the
right person i'm sure monogamy is a pain
in the ass if you end up with the wrong
person but
having not ended up with the wrong
person uh i'm i'm all in favor
okay so what did what what did i blow
past well
no no you you said it but it was just
like so fast and the idea
so that it's multifaceted too the idea
is the conflict
between that fraction of the genome of
the fetus
that comes from the father uh the
conflict between that
fraction of the genome and the mother is
much greater if the father is
out of there and therefore has no
interest or little interest in the
ongoing well-being of the
mother and has an interest in his
offspring taking more than its share
whereas if you have a monogamous system
where the next offspring is going to be
his as well he has a much more
concordant interest
and the fetuses have a concordant
interest because
the next offspring is going to be a full
sib rather than a half sib
reduces sibling rivalry so does
yeah it's just a better system it's just
better
yeah i think it might have been horses
i'll look it up
all right yeah um
wait so i'm not sure we finished though
you were saying you were surprised that
i
wasn't didn't think the agricultural
revolution would have had much to do
with it because
oh because of the the well-feddedness of
the babies and we went
to fat heads and then we went to genomic
imprinting yeah got it see
we just recapped the whole interchange
right there yep
all right next question if there was a
less lethal ancestor virus and it spread
in an area near wuhan in southern china
would you expect to see higher immunity
in the same countries reporting very
little spread of the current virus for
instance
china vietnam taiwan
i think tw stands for taiwan
a less lethal variant that spread
beforehand well first of all i would
certainly expect
evidence of that um but yeah you could
but so i think the question is taking
that part
on like suppose this yeah there's a less
lethal ancestor virus and it spread
near wuhan if that were the case would
you expect to see higher immunity in the
same countries reporting very little
spread of the current virus
definitely definitely so so i mean i
think the question basically is could we
take what we actually see empirically in
terms of countries that had low
um infection rates as possibly evidence
not you know not not verifying but
possibly evidence
in you know light evidence in support of
a hypothesis that there was something
circulating
not exactly um so i would say i see
no reason to believe this happened but
if we take it as a hypothetical what if
it had happened would we expect
this pattern yes that we do see yeah um
but
no i don't see the i don't see any
evidence any affirmative evidence of
this
at all but yes you could take it as a
hypothesis and then you would want
what would you look what would we look
for though as as um
as affirmative evidence or or falsifying
really although um you know like you
know background
you know antibodies in members of the
population that didn't appear to have
yes you would want to know that a that
the low rates were the result of
immunity but b
we also know that there but that
evidence may fail because we see
you know antibody titers fading so
quickly with this dam virus
well but you know the thing is what we
have is immunological memory and so
the antibodies aren't durable but the
memory cells are
and so okay yeah in any case you would
expect to see
uh evidence of that you know i'm not
sure we would call it
uh even an epidemic if let's say it was
close to asymptomatic but
um but in any case you would expect to
see evidence of that
pathogen and the problem is that we know
that a lot of things there's even
cross-reactivity between things like
cold viruses and covid
so that's a much bigger gap
so we would want to see something
narrower than that
and as far as i know there's no evidence
whatsoever
all right we also yeah we we effectively
have a point source
in in wuhan so that marshalls against it
this is a question from the discord
server this week where
if you are on the discord server um as i
imagine many
of the people who are sticking around
for these private q and a's
are these uh these super chat q as um
are um but you get access to the discord
server
by joining one of our patreons and then
they vote on their favorite question for
the week and ask it
this week's question is for the majority
of our evolutionary history survival was
a challenge
this seems to have built us to endure
hardship and struggle almost need it
how much does the lack of struggle
required to survive in modern society
contribute to current issues
mental health ideologies polarization
and how can we guide people towards
positive struggle
like perhaps mastering a craft or
getting a phd or running a marathon
i love it when the questions answer
themselves they know um i mean
a lot of the questions on the discord
server do that they you know there's
they're so
thoughtful and careful and um and
and have the q and the a both in there
right yep so yes but you know
but the question the question that
remains is how so
it seemed to be asking you know would it
be useful to guide people towards
positive struggle yes
and you know how how do we do that is
is maybe a harder societal question well
as you start young the thing is yes you
start young
and you you know it's actually in some
ways the same
thing that we were addressing at the top
with respect to
analogies to evolution so one of the
things i would say
is there is a very
tight connection between development and
evolution many of the patterns are
quite analogous and what you want is to
provide a
pathway that rewards the behavior that
ultimately manifests in being good at
struggling against things worth
struggling against
and you know to the extent that you you
know and this is in part why we end up
so different from each other
is that we happen to have experiences
early on in which something really
rewarding happens on some channel
and that may be total luck the first
time or the second time that it happens
but it may result in you feeling like
hey i wonder if i have an aptitude for
that thing and then
you pursue it and then you get
frustrated when it doesn't work and
so you get better and better and so the
point is for those of us who educate or
for those of us with kids
the question is can you architect the
experience that causes the thing that
turns out awesome in the end
to be rewarding along the way enough
that you stick to it and you get
frustrated in a useful way rather than a
dumb way and
um how do you um
how do you create an internal motivation
system an internal reward system
rather than um you know what
what of course the government and the
pharmaceutical companies and the media
and advertisers and everyone who sells
stuff wants which is to maintain an
external motivating system
which uh rewards with carrots and other
delicious things and
punishes with sticks yes less delicious
sticks than carrots unless you're a dog
no carrots are still more delicious than
sticks you're right
yeah it's it's really like a flavored
stick on some level but yeah
um yeah the uh
so i do think there's something to
the useful frustration versus stupid
frustration
for sure and um you know i know
in my own case the object that doesn't
work
i get frustrated that it doesn't work
and i feel
that i am obligated to figure out if i
can determine what it is that doesn't
work and get it to work which then gives
me a
you know presumably a head of dopamine i
feel the same way about
photography especially nature
photography where
you know every uh aside from those rare
dumb luck instances you know the
the machine the camera is a bundle of
constraints
and the event or the creature or the
creature doing its thing
is an opportunity and there's definitely
a sense of like
can i figure out enough of the puzzle to
actually get an image that i'd be
interested in showing somebody
um into the machine you know uh
and and then there's the what i never
thought i would care about really
um the change in the way cameras work
has radically changed the puzzles that
you have to solve as a photographer some
things that we used to care a hell of a
lot about he just there's no reason to
care at all
and other things you know are now
obsessions and
so anyway there's something about um
a a love of puzzle solving and then
finding the puzzles
that work and one of the things i worry
about is that
um because that thing is liable to have
been
rewarded evolutionarily we are built
to find our passions and to figure out
how to solve problems in them
but what happens when somebody comes up
with the junk food solution
to that thing and it's like oh this
video game is
really visually compelling and you know
what there are actual people
in it that you can you know banter back
and forth with as you
game right and it's like wow that's
everything i want but the point is it
doesn't train you to do anything useful
it doesn't train you to solve
problems in some useful way and so the
point is it's all up
well what do i really know i don't game
but um
i think it's all opportunity cost and
the opportunity cost comes in the form
of all of the
things you could have trained yourself
to do that later on would still be
meaningful
whereas a game is going to disappear and
who cares that you're good at some game
that doesn't exist anymore
we could say a lot more about all of
this question but let's move on
yep uh after watching your discussion
with jamie wheel
i'm wondering if you are still pursuing
a unity platform for 2022 or 2024.
um unity is alive and well
and in an invisible form we are going to
reboot it it is not however inherently
about elections it is about the fact
that there is in general
policy that serves our collective
well-being
that is not finding a place in
governance because our governance is
so [ __ ] corrupt if you don't mind my
saying so
so the point is start thinking about
unity more broadly
yes winning elections is cool and
strategies for doing so is cool
but more broadly think of all of the
things that we would do if we were smart
that we're not doing because
we've got corrupt leaders and those
things
are really the heart of unity and i
think
frankly it's vastly more interesting
than a narrow electorally focused
version of that thing so anyway let's
think more broadly and
let's let's have fun fighting the good
fight
cool
what is your flaw excuse me um
what is your philosophy on medical care
for pets
oh wait a minute
there were a few questions that were in
two parts and i was
i okay maybe this wasn't a two-part one
what is your philosophy on medical care
for pets that is cost aside
how do you evaluate whether to subject a
pet to surgery or medical treatment
uh well you want to go or should i go
you you you can go i'll i'll add i mean
we've
we've done a lot of medical care for our
pets yes we have um
i would say this is a tough one um
because you know i mean the philosophy
is what you're asking about and that's a
good question
i would say at some level i see you as
taking on the responsibility of a
creature worthy of care
and that in effect because they are pets
and because they don't
live as long as people you are
hopefully in the position of taking them
on
presumably when they're young in general
and seeing them through their life and
basically
i think the right thing to do is to
attempt
to make sure that bad things don't
happen to them
and that if they are jeopardized by
pathology that you make
the right decision rather than this a
decision that is overly focused on your
own
horror at losing your pet um so
you know keeping your pet alive is great
when you can do it and it's
just a matter of money that you happen
to have
on the other hand um i have to say that
couple times that we have had to put
animals
to sleep uh to euthanize them i love the
euphemism i don't know why i used it but
um i have had the sense of like this is
incredibly painful
but there is also a sense of
you know i took care of you you know
right to the the end i was there at the
moment that you
left and you know and that that means
that nothing terrible happened to you in
the meantime
and um i do think
you know as you and i have talked
endlessly about something awful has
happened to veterinary
care it's become predatory the way uh
so-called death care is predatory
basically because the emotions are so
heightened there's a business
opportunity
and somehow we have to find
veterinarians who will help us make the
right decision rather than do what they
do which is a
feed us a lot of stuff that's probably
not good for the animal and probably not
necessary
and b push us towards
intervening to prolong life
when that doesn't make sense to do yeah
we i'm reminded of um one of one of our
cats whom we ultimately did euthanize
at the age of 17 or 18 i don't remember
how old sasha was
um but within a year or so of the end of
her life so she was already
quite an old cat uh she had white ears
and she got
cancer in here melanoma or
her ears yeah and we said no we're not
gonna have this
elderly cat whom we love live the last
probably months of her life without ears
yeah without ears and being horrifying
to people who
encountered her and it just didn't make
any sense because she was you know at
the end of her life one way or the other
yeah um uh so anyway yeah i would say
you do have obligations to your pet and
you know nobody likes the idea of people
who
um treat pets like objects and get rid
of them at the point they're
inconvenient that's horrifying
when they move i mean it's just right
really really a good indication of
someone that you don't want to
be dependent on for anything right
people who do that but
um you know there there has to be a
balance struck and really the thing is
you know give your pet an excellent life
and it's actually
in some ways i think the most um
it's the most marvelous gift you can
give a creature
is a life that's well taken care of you
know that in which they
have interesting things to do but they
don't have to worry about
uh anything big like starvation or
predation or
or anything like that um
and you know we don't even give this to
our kids like you know you raise kids
and
they face uh trials and tribulations and
that's part of life
but well they have to become uh
independent in the way the cats don't
right exactly exactly
next question as one who uses anonymity
for political effect myself
that antifa dude in the anonymous e
video is tactically effective but
morally appalling
using people's ire for wheeler to do
more harm than good not realizing he's
ushering in a fascist response
so no question there but an apt comment
yeah i totally agree with this
and you know i think it's uh
i it is important to recognize that as
much as that looked like anonymous the
message was not like anonymous
um and uh you know we
one of the problems and i think this is
a problem that is true of anonymous is
because of the nature of anonymous
it's a non-organization which in effect
liberates anybody to put on that mask
and deliver the anonymous message
there's nothing that can say hey that
one doesn't speak for us because what is
us
right so that's a problem and in this
case we
now see what that problem does is that
somebody can use the style of anonymous
to threaten the mayor of portland
and there's no one to say oh that's
that's not a real
anonymous message because who's to say
one way or the other
um but yes it is a serious problem
hello a question that i've not seen
talked about is if the wuhan lab was
studying the covet virus
why does it appear that they've been a
non-player in terms of vaccine or other
useful information
um because they've been hiding under
their desks
yeah trying to dodge responsibility yeah
they
they only acknowledge that they have a
virus that is
related uh and i don't think they even
claimed to have
had pulled it out of cold storage or
however it's stored no i mean
in fact there were many claims made
along the way that there was no virus
left that their their ancestor was
reduced to a sequence and
yeah there's nothing in their freezer
and the thing is the obvious thing to do
would have been to
um look in their freezer yeah among
other things
of course they could well have
disappeared yes but yeah their absence
from the scene is
conspicuous on the other hand uh i can
say
if they had entered into this
conversation about
vaccines and and what to do i can
imagine
uh a healthy dose of skepticism directed
their way
and so one can imagine let's say let's
say that the wuhan institute isn't
is innocent right one can still imagine
that they would not have been in a good
position to contribute to this effort
and might have sidelined themselves on
that basis
yep
um i can't help but think of the
i can't help but think of the perverse
incentive for big pharma and tech
oligarchs like bill
to be incentivized by disasters it's not
hard to make the leap between gain and
function and capital gains
call me a conspiracy gal be a lot more
easy and this is
second question from the same person or
comment be a lot more
easy to trust the cdc if they didn't
switch pandemics between kevin 19
racism and climate change color me
skeptical
yeah um i'm
we're obviously in the same boat and the
problem is
all of these things we need a functional
cdc we need a functional cdc
we need functional governance and um you
know back to the question about unity
it's the corruption stupid that's what's
causing this to all be so difficult
which doesn't mean you wouldn't be left
with a very difficult problem
if the corruption wasn't there but the
point is the corruption means this is
not going to be solved in our interest
right it's going to be solved behind
closed doors according to things that
you know we're all too naive to
understand
unfortunately yeah um this is just
another comment
tongue-in-cheek taking social
justification for vaccination to its
logical conclusion
shouldn't you not vaccinate because if
you're healthy you won't get
covered 19 then you don't need it and if
you die it's one less unhealthy person
that society would have had to take care
of
in the future boy that is uh that's the
route to herd immunity
reducto absurdum yup there it is there
it is
uh last time i traveled to entebbe
i'm sure i'm butchering that name in
uganda i had to show evidence on my who
vaccination card of yellow fever
inoculation upon entry
why are people acting like this passport
is a new thing you know i actually
talked about this somewhat extensively
on bridget fedex's
uh podcast a couple weeks ago um so
i'm i'm not gonna go through it here but
um basically one of the answers
is um well a few things
um being asked to be vaccinated to
travel someplace that is not your home
to protect the lives of the people who
already live there is very different
from being told that you may lose rights
and privileges to live in your own home
the way you've been living
before that said pandemic legitimate
pandemic does potentially change some of
that thinking
and the yellow fever vaccination is a
decades-old traditional vaccine with
literally decades of um health and
safety
data safety and efficacy data behind it
uh
which makes it a very different vaccine
and you know this was my point actually
to bridget as well
you know i you know i had to and i had
to require all of my students
um to have yellow fever and some other
but yellow fever vaccination in
particular that was the only one that
i i i had to get and we had to get and
then i had to require my students to get
when i would take them
deep into the amazon there's literally a
military checkpoint
where you show your card and if you
don't have it you get turned back
and frankly the responsibility for you
as someone coming into a space to help
keep the local population
safe is a very different situation yeah
it is a very different situation
um in effect you have the right to make
rules for people coming in
of course that makes sense uh right yeah
now um i would say also
there is i don't know anything about the
business behind
the yellow fever vaccine but it's such a
tiny number of people who get that shot
um every year especially as a result of
passports
and i don't know about vaccines but if
if if they're patented
the same way you know it's literally
been in production for many many decades
it must be out of patent i got it as a
kid well no i i know it's been in use
since
it's i can't remember now it's been a
couple of weeks but it's like
1930s 1940s way before you were a kid so
my point is i don't know
if if patents work differently for
vaccines or what but i don't think that
there's a huge profit to be made
right i don't think there's a huge
profit to be made because you'll have
lots of manufacturers and the one thing
i don't know is whether or not the
yellow vaccine is still the
yellow fever vaccine sounds like you
have established that it's the same
vaccine yeah
so anyway perverse incentives aren't
there history of
safety of the vaccine is clear yeah
um and so anyway and and it's
you know it's a requirement to go to x y
or z place
i should say require being required to
carry papers to walk around your own
country
that is um there's a lot of bad
historical precedent there
and it's it's you know it's not the same
as being forced to have a driver's
license to drive or to have a
yellow fever vaccination card to enter
you know ecuador or you know whatever
it's just not the same
and we have you know
clear evidence of perverse incentives
and a
massive uh profit to be made for
requiring everybody i would also point
if you'll go back to
one of our early live streams we talked
about this issue
of what i called monkeying with the
baseline oh yeah and
um by forcing everyone to get vaccinated
they are also
monkeying with the baseline with respect
to our ability to establish what the
consequences
uh actually are that in effect uh
if you did have universal vaccination
then you don't have a control group so
it won't be quite universal but if they
can get close then
um then it also means we can't quite
test
the question of what happened yeah
um two more
i think sort of follow-ups to that
question from the same person
or just comments um
boy it's actually two different people
uh with slightly different initials
um i so that person says i'd rather roll
the dice with my pfizer shots
then get covered and see those long-term
health effects they don't seem awesome
and then follows up with love bretton
heather i have a science undergrad and
social science masters i'm now a manager
my job is making many critical decisions
based on incomplete information
it's an art and a science my gut says
just take the backs
so i would point out that
it's very hard to know what to make of
this result
that you just told me about for the
first time today i think you just
which one ran across it this result that
the spike protein in and of its brand
creates damage yeah it's it's a brand
new model organism now it's possible
that that
is an anomaly it's possible that the
paper doesn't mean what we think it
means
or that it has to do with the model
organism and not people
but if it is true and i will say it has
the ring of truth because
it's not only that it does damage it
does exactly the kind of damage that we
see that is so anomalous with covid
it's consistent with it being vascular
disease and not preparing the
respiratory
right exactly so if that is the case
then think about what you're saying
right you're saying that a healthy
person
should take a dose of a
pathological
a pathological vaccine so i'm not saying
that this
is the case i'm saying if it is the case
then a vaccine that creates spike
protein that itself
induces damage is an acceptable risk to
avoid
the same kind of damage from the virus
now i'm not discounting how serious
this virus damage is it's very serious
and it has been practically a mantra
since the beginning
of these live streams people are
underrating the danger of kovid
because the death rate the case fatality
rate is low
right they are underrating the damage
because it's years of life lost from the
damage to major organs
that we see regularly in these cases
um but that the vaccine is not
it's you know i think people have this
sense about
if i get away with it in the short term
then i got away with it and that's just
not how this works with a complex system
like this so
um i i hear ya you may be right but you
need to leave open the possibility that
you're not right and that in fact a
a vaccine that itself does
significant damage to the body is
it's not a free pass yeah
next question hello a friend of mine
loves biology and has gone back to
college to major in it but she's not
sure what you can actually do with that
degree
do you have any advice or resources for
bio students in that position
um yeah jeez you know yeah
i remember back in the before times when
you and i were professors
and the questions i liked least were
questions
in which people wanted either advice on
continuing their education into graduate
school or
careers that might be based on such
things because
the world has gone crazy and it takes
advantage of graduate students
who end up doing the teaching of the
university
for cheap and there are no jobs for them
when they get out
and it leaves a lot of people um
bitter and with a degree they can't use
having spent some of their
potentially most productive years um
doing something they wouldn't have done
if they realized there wasn't going to
be a profession at the end of it
so when you're talking about grad school
this is someone going back to
um major to get a baccalaureate a
bachelor's degree
um which is um which you know opens up
you know even even fewer things except
that um to the degree that a college
degree is still worth anything
yep um i think a degree in a science
uh is going to be increasingly better
regarded as a degree
in um some other fields because
it at least demonstrates that you have
an ability to you know think
logically and mathematically sometimes
hopefully unless
hopefully it still does hopefully right
um
and i guess with regard to anything more
precise
like a we don't really in part because
the future is not going to look a lot
like the past
but also biology is huge and really you
know if she's
if she's interested in ecology versus
cellular biology versus genetics
uh versus molecular biology evolution um
it's you know
all of the possible career paths would
be different
yep um but i think i think the analysis
you came up with is right which is
if you're going because you need a
college degree then you might as well
study something real and
interesting to you and biology would be
uh
as good or from our perspective better
than most
um so if you think about it as two
separate things what you're doing is
you're getting the degree
what are you getting the degree in
something that you're fascinated by then
it makes
a kind of sense
so next question so could the risk of
covet 19 be the reason for passports and
contact tracing
to protect the industry from a potential
media fallout that would be caused
by mrna risks to invent
the narrative with variance not totally
sure what that means
yeah i don't quite get it either but i i
am
concerned about the um
i'm concerned about what we are not told
about consequences that people have
i'm concerned about being tracked
um and all sorts of things that if you
know if we lived in a world where these
things were done
functionally and honorably i wouldn't be
worried about it and i'd be in favor of
it but yeah
in maya for starters appeal the defense
put forward that society has
moved on from biological reality
what are the realities do you think we
will move on from in the name of
postmodernism
um oh my god so i have not been
following the appeal
much um i think it's going well this is
um my enforced daughter who was
um fired um for
believing in the reality of sex and for
saying so
um and the original case um
found that they had just cause because
it was i don't know i don't even
remember the and this is uk so i know
even less about the legal system but um
somehow she was in the wrong
uh for recognizing reality um so this
appeal i think is
is is i thought it was already over
gosh i i wish i knew that is awesome um
and um anyway the question here
is the the defense actually argued
that society has moved on from
biological reality
so i i'm actually i'm gubsmacked
yes yes gobsmacked it's another one of
those texas expressions
um yeah so
let's put it this way i mean we've
already found ourselves
in the place where if
it is unthinkable that we will move past
some realization then we will move past
it you know two plus two equals four
is pretty much an announcement that we
have hit bottom
and um you got people out there actually
believing they're different species and
right and so i mean in in essence what
you have to imagine
and again we've just been saying this
for what feels like
forever but it's you know a year or
a little more um the
thing is people who
believe this crap or pretend they
believe this crap
are hobbling themselves in competition
with
anybody who can figure out how to keep
doing the real
the reality thing so those people are
going to win
those people could be china it could be
it could be anyone and so
the point is we will very soon
rediscover the reality of reality
right that is coming one way or the
other whether that's
through uh the hegemony of others
or the extinction of the species or
whatever it is but
you know uh nature bats last as it were
and
um you can only dodge um
realism for so long well i guess
actually that's that feels to me like a
good segue to this next question
um which is the only good segue is a
dead segway and i say that with respect
to personal electric vehicles
you know you're not helping right
it's becoming apparent yes
well it's a bad time oh we finally got
here
okay see they're not obviously linked
and i was trying to make a connection
and you're
introduced stepped on your connection
rando vehicles that don't even exist i
mean do they exist anymore
sure and it's spelled differently you
know that right i do not know that yeah
the two segways
okay i didn't actually know that for a
while is there a way to get from one
spelling to the other
that would be in keeping with the term
yeah you can go the first three letters
and then you just get
blocked yeah yeah yeah okay
the next question is harris only speaks
the truth at the moment that serves her
she ran on outreach to this exact ilk
her and her staffers contributed funds
to bail for protesters
her principles are weathervane blown by
ego and greed
and this is basically what you were
arguing and i had this you know naive
optimism
um and i was before i read that question
i was actually going to say yeah you
know what you're right i'm actually
surprised that i was
hopeful in in light of what um what i
have seen from her in the past
but i think actually the reason
that i do take it as hopeful in one way
is
i mean politicians will politic you know
like that she's gonna do what she does i
would
i would love it if there was actually a
total change of heart but i don't expect
that from her so that's not what i was
hopeful about like oh maybe she's
becoming
you know the vice president we all want
and deserve i don't expect that to be
the case
um i thought that it could mean and this
is consistent with the idea that
carville said something very similar
this week
that actually they're seeing the writing
on the wall and that basically the
democratic party does have the capacity
to
to pull the rip cord on wokeness
potentially
they actually they actually do and so
you know
we're going to move on from biological
reality in the name of postmodernism
at some point some people with power are
going to
realize exactly what you just said well
we're just gonna lose then
if we keep playing this game we're just
going to lose
and um the sooner people with
who are wielding power see that
cynical though that seeing is um the
more likely we can turn this around well
i
would not want to be those on a segway
dnc stalwarts
at the point that the army of people
with
npr tote bags realize that they've been
had by a bunch of people
cynically selling them wokeness because
they're going to get a
a thwacking of some kind no they're very
agreeable yeah they are
too agreeable but um yeah i
don't i don't know i mean i think the
question asker has it exactly right
the way to model these people's behavior
and predict it correctly is to imagine
that they're completely cynical
and then i would just add to that that
they're also fools and therefore
don't understand yes but again you're
focusing on the individual and i was
saying that my hopefulness was about the
popular societal level response that
we need we need enough people to be
recognizing this to turn this around
right imagine that i don't care about
kamala harris but here's the problem
here's the problem they have empowered
this thing and
the dnc sure and its partners and so
anyway my claim from the beginning has
been they don't believe this crap
that they are granted so but well the
other thing i've said is they don't have
the power to control it so watching them
wake up
is predicted this is a little earlier
than i would have expected
but um you know maybe this is maybe but
you really think they don't have an
ability to move the dial
uh yeah i i think these people haven't
understood the game theory that has
driven this things
this far and so you know they've
basically thrown gasoline
on this fire and at the point that they
realize that they're not so happy with
it
um they're gonna get oh they've got us
more gasoline all they've got is more
gas
yep well i hope you're wrong yeah i do
too
yeah did you catch josh rogan on
joe rogan loudly not only possible but
probable given the huge smoking gun of
the cover-up
thoughts feel vindicated keep up the
good work much love from france
i did not see josh rogan on i saw that
he was on i did not
uh see it
vindicated is a weird term yeah i think
the thing that i feel is okay
can we play this through so that we're
not in the situation next time
right the fact that we managed to get
lab leak to the point that it can be
discussed in polite company
was incredibly dangerous and
it was incredibly difficult and it was
unlikely to work
right we managed because there were a
lot of very clever people
who had the chops to navigate the
evidence there were a lot of us who were
willing to talk about it
in public to this one did not come out
the way they usually do
but the point is you know that
force that wants to tell us what to
think
is there it's screwed up in this case
can we now extrapolate to the other
stuff that it's clearly lying to us
about right which doesn't make any of
this clear my point in the
uh first part of the podcast was that
what you need
is a huge budget for nuance in all of
these cases because it doesn't marshal
towards one team or the other it
marshals towards these
uh intermediate ambiguous gray as can be
answers um but you know the next time
we're not going to get
uh so lucky and
let's just learn from this case yeah i
guess
i would i'm just picking up on your um
you're focusing on that word vindicated
i think it's um
it's a dangerous word to be thinking
about in this landscape precisely
because
if lab leak turns out to be the actual
origin
of sarsko v2 um it is true that it was
something that you
and we were talking about early
we should have been interested in and
willing to talk about that early
if it was simply a possibility no matter
how likely it seemed to us or how likely
it actually was
and so you want people who are actually
good faith careful thinkers to be saying
this thing is a possibility and that
thing's a possibility
all the time and have in fact depending
on how many hypotheses
they are talking about for any given
explanation mostly not have those
hypotheses be borne out
like that that is what that is what
discerning between hypotheses is about
it's the very rare situation
where you have two and only two and
there's one that's being promoted
and the you know black sheep hypothesis
is actually the true one and
you're there you know talking about the
black sheep hypothesis that's a that's a
super rare situation that's not even
descriptive of what
um is is going on here so you want all
the possible hypotheses on the table
and it is certainly true that with all
the perverse incentives that we know
there to be
know there to be in the world right now
that there will always be one or two or
many
that aren't really being discussed and
you want people
everyone but people like us will tend to
be
those saying app there's also this
possibility even if we don't even think
it's true
but that's a possibility let us
establish what the complete solution set
of possibilities are
and if those possibilities that we've
now
added to what we think is a complete
solution set of possibilities
don't end up being right that doesn't
mean we were wrong
to bring them up that means that those
hypotheses weren't correct right it has
nothing to do with being vindicated or
not
it has to do with we need to get all of
the possible hypotheses on the table so
we can talk freely
i totally agree with this and you know
again it's not the most intuitive thing
in the world but
yeah the ability to formally put
hypotheses on the table
and you know in general we do have an
opinion about what hypotheses we think
are most likely it has
enough has no implication whatsoever for
whether you put them on the table
correctly you've said what the
predictions would be if they were true
and then you find out if they are yeah
but i would also just to wrap this up
point out something interesting is going
on here because
the lab leak turns out to be probable
we were able to see that back in
april may last april may of last year
the
vaccine looks like it has risks
this is brand new but this issue of the
spike protein the vaccine appears to
have risks beyond what one would expect
based on
um the pr masks
don't need to be worn outdoors like
why are we getting these things when
everybody else is
way behind on them right you know that
has to do
with the freedom to just simply do the
analysis
right so the fact that you have
virtually nobody who has the ability to
do the analysis based on
you know their training and history and
science and the freedom to do the
analysis based on the career that they
hold
is killing us yes the perversion centers
are all over the goddamn place
and the fact is if you want to be
healthy
and you know act in your interest and
society's interest
then you know you need more people who
are free to talk
yeah right and you know that's the thing
we should really be shocked at
is how few people are in a position to
do it yes
um two more questions here and then
we'll move on to
uh this hour's questions if it were up
to you two
what would you propose should happen in
india right now
should only the vulnerable take the
vaccine doesn't this guarantee the
continuous spread and mutation of the
virus
i don't have an answer to this
i don't know a tremendous amount about
what's going on in india um
in part because i have i have not looked
at it carefully because i know there
will be so much missing
and um i'm not in a position to figure
out what's missing
um which makes um seeing what is being
portrayed to us um even harder to
decipher when you don't even know what
the holes are yeah i must say i'm
resistant to answering questions like
this because in a sense my feeling is
um were we in charge
we would not have gotten here because we
would have taken this much more
seriously
much earlier and the fact i don't i
don't really want responsibility for
you know there's something where you're
drifting
towards a waterfall right and there are
clever things to do
early in that process and the number of
clever things there are to do get
smaller and smaller the closer you are
you get to the waterfall and then
there's a point at which you can't
escape the waterfall
and you know the last thing i want is
okay what would you do at that point and
it's like well i would
probably die yeah i wouldn't have gotten
this close to the waterfall yeah right i
would have paid attention to it a lot
earlier and i would have been a lot more
careful
so i appreciate the question i think
it's a fair question and frankly i hope
really good people are on it
yeah um but hey i would like to know
more about what is going on
in india and why um which i don't think
is straightforward and i know that we
can't have that conversation
based on uh the reception that
gert van der bush has received now i'm
not saying that that is what's happening
in india because
the vaccination rate i don't think is
high enough
for that to be the explanation though it
could be i'm not even sure it's on a
population basis that we would do that
analysis because really
it's a question of absolute numbers and
rare variants arising but
um but in any case there's a lot to be
thought that's right
i would love a room full of uh
well-informed free people
to have that discussion in a place we
could overhear it
okay one last question from this hour um
also something i don't know
about um the new yorker published a
game-changing ufo feature yesterday
more ex-dod officials department of
defense officials have made comments
suggesting that aliens exist on earth
but outside of the range of human
perception
thoughts i don't know anything about
this
there are none behind you you can't tell
you're human right i assumed they were
just standing in our blind spots
that's what i thought was being
suggested but maybe not usually
beyond the range of human perception uh
has already factored in the blind spots
yeah so uh let's put it this way do you
know anything about this article i
haven't i didn't
even know the article existed well my
son seems like something i should do one
of a series of things that has emerged
recently that suggests the military is
taking this ufo stuff
um seriously really yeah um
you know this well but i mean remember
ufo just means unidentified um
yeah aliens is a step beyond that uh i
let's put it this way i kind of hope
that it's aliens because if it's aliens
maybe we're saved
and maybe we're doomed what
no honestly i've thought about you know
as you
find out that you have no power to
affect the ship of fools that is headed
towards the waterfall
you start thinking well what might work
and one thing that might work
is aliens who know what the [ __ ] is
going on and we could talk to them about
it and
you know at least it might just put a
shock to the system and we would start
to
realize where we are who we are
what it means what matters and we could
you know
team up on this coveted thing and stop
in
yeah good all right so i hope it's
aliens and i hope they don't want to
kill us i think
there's no real reason they would it's a
nice planet
it was pretty good but you know oh it's
a great planet
for what i mean it's good oh i guess
no i just i think the thing is we're
talking about um
aliens i mean it's in our goldilocks
zone i don't know if it's in their
goldilocks zone but if they're already
here
it probably is right but my
sense is we're talking about
sufficient technological sophistication
that you don't think they arrived by
intergalactic spore
i think that if they're here it's a
result of some pretty good tech
which means they probably don't need
anything from us though i heard tack i
imagine them like
tacking through the galaxy that'd be
cool on the solar winds
yeah i i like it yeah but you know
between between
star systems there's not a lot of solar
winds
and of course we have to uh we have to
give eric his due
do we i think we do i don't know for
what yet um because his point is we got
to get off this rock true true
and uh getting off this rock may not
involve what people think and i'm still
i must say a super skeptic of the fact
that
a physical possibility of crossing
large amounts of space without actually
going through it and therefore
you know beating the speed of light
without going
it's a great idea um but let's put it
this way
if there are aliens hovering in our
blind spot
then they probably got here they're not
in our blind spot we just can't perceive
them
i'm using it metaphorically now but it's
different i'm enjoying the idea of
aliens in all of our blind spots
in our species level blind spot in our
species level blind spot
yeah exactly okay the bees know
the bees know yeah um the
so in any case if they're here they
probably got here
in some way and this drives our crazy if
we say faster than
light because he imagines that we all
think that means
going faster than light rather than
getting from a to b faster than light
can go from a to b which is what you
mean eric um but if they're here then
they probably did it in which case
it might not be crazy on this point
that's another reason you want the
aliens to be here
it's a failure to falsify eric's
hypothesis
yes eric's theory of everything would be
an extreme
failure of falsification of eric's
hypothesis of everything which would
then be a theory there it is
all right excellent good did it
yep okay well we're going to answer some
questions from the next
we're just about an hour
which was enough time to get from alpha
centauri to here
were you able to pull those two that
takes nothing
nothing no no no none of it takes
anything none of it
are nothing yeah they're uh
they're they're they're they're passe
their passion as well by the way you
know yesterday i was picking up
toby at school and i was thinking
school is now old school
it's true old school is new again i
guess i realized the other day with him
and this will be true for our deputy
producer for a different number
um this will be true for many people
with children but because of the timing
and the lockdowns and the fact that
school has only just
barely partially begun to resume in
person for toby
um when he was 14 years old
he had no school in person he basically
saw no one and the same is true for our
then 16 year old deputy producer zachary
an entire
entire year yes i'm confused
i thought zach was the producer and
fairfax was the deputy producer
who did i did i just call someone deputy
producer you called zach
oh no no i'm sorry you have not been
demoted
in fact i'm promoting you after this as
an apology
yeah thank you yeah we can make him
benevolent overlord of the dark horse
podcast no i think we just double up his
title you're going to be the producer
producer
oh okay good
and we'll make you the head of the
department of redundancy department
a recent ant invasion made curious made
me curious presumably
is there an organism or super organism
to which
if you found out it was cohabitating
with you and wanted your house
you would seed the habitat
yeah i need to know this
grizzly bears if you find yourself
cohabitating with a grizzly bear and it
decides
it wants the house it's under duress
this is seed it's not if it's under
arrest
i would i would make whatever allowance
well i wouldn't
stand up to them you're standing up to
the grizzly bear yeah
i'm not sure that's a good idea just
look up to them but yes
yeah yeah no willingly seed the house
well here's something though which which
you probably won't know unless you spent
time
in the neotropics um our very first
field season together as as would-be
researchers in grad school we had spent
a summer traveling around
central america already but
we were at a very tiny field station in
sarapiki in
northeastern costa rica which is
basically a house
that was run by a small family
a woman and a man and their young child
and then they had rooms for
for researchers and it was just us and a
few other grad students
and our professor and it was associated
with a
with a smallish piece of forest at one
point the army ants
um were coming and i don't remember do
you remember what are you doing
i'm looking for a neotropical companion
okay
um so i but i need your attention
you got it undivided except for my
looking for
the relevant book on the shelf there
yeah it's been a long day it has been um
do you remember how it was that we came
to know that the army ants were coming
like when you were in the forest you
sometimes run into the army ants um
when um and you're like okay i get it i
see it i'm just gonna stare steer clear
but
i don't remember if it was one of us one
of the grad students or john our
professor
or indeed lavinia or i can't remember
the dude who actually ran the field
sister i remember the woman's name his
name
is okay anyway i don't remember who it
was
and from how much of a distance it
became clear that okay actually the army
ants are coming in they're probably
coming here
and lavinia i remember the the woman the
wife
basically said no this is great when
they come it's cleaning
so we just you know you gotta you gotta
get you gotta clear out anything that
you don't want them to
clean and because if it's organic
they'll get rid of it
and they might move stuff away if it's
light and they just feel like it's in
the way but
as long as you can basically clear out
your stuff
and leave it to them you come back to a
gleaming kitchen
and bathrooms and the army ends just
come through
like a wave and i don't know how long it
takes for a smallish house but
you know less than a day oh yeah flowers
um and so um i would temporarily seed
a house if i had one in the neotropics
to army ants
not grizzly bears all right well so in
order to
make the story good i think we should we
should
say that we were alerted to the approach
of the army ants by the ant birds that
would be
appropriate biologically accurate yeah
but i don't think we were i'm sure we
weren't but yeah
um anyway but we can make that claim
here we'll do the wizard
yeah it was the ant birds which you know
we could recognize at
50 paces with the help of an
ornithologist and a field guide
there you go um yeah so yeah that
actually happened several times on bci
too when i was there and i was looking
for a neo-tropical companion which i
believe describes exactly that
phenomenon
companion or tropical nature no i think
it's neotropical companion describes it
i'm sure it's really
out there but i'm i'm not going to get
up yeah but enough screen yeah
like i do during our private q and a's
it happens every now and again
and there's nothing to be done about it
yeah and you know yeah it's not terrible
if
you just let them go yeah most of the
stuff that if i found them in my house i
would be pleased with i wouldn't want to
seed the house i would want to come to
an
agreement like you know if it turns out
that kinkajous were living in the
rafters you'd be like that's cool can we
potty train you
right no it's a mistake i mean this is
more or less what one does with children
they're usually not in the rafters but
sometimes yeah
that happens every now and again usually
at least mothers aren't surprised to
find the arrival of the children
right not it's hard to be caught that
off guard yeah but nonetheless you
discovered them in your house and
i know i wasn't you know well maybe you
were yeah
that surprise as a bat biologist how do
you feel
got the questions this week oh no
as a pet biologist how do you feel about
the term sky puppies for these critters
in parallel to sea puppies for seals and
land puppies for dogs
i ain't never heard that term i don't i
i think i i think
it's being made up yeah i think it is
being made up um
the old world fruit bats the terrapodi
are known as flying foxes a reference to
their dog-like appearance
but they are much more reference to
their fox-like appearance isn't it
they're not called flying dogs being
caniforms
right yeah okay they're dogs other
candidates okay okay yeah um
fair enough and most objection retracted
thank you you're welcome most bats do
not look that much like dogs
um and in fact we have none of those
terrapods in the new world
nope um so i'm i'm skeptical we do
describe maddie as like a land
seal a landsale and i must say cl's two
strike means very dog-like wait and in
jamaica
yes the names for bats and moths oh yes
right moths are bats and
bats are rat bats there it is yeah yeah
you learned when you were
working as bob trevor's field assistant
many many years ago yeah
in jamaica all right uh noses look
expensive
why do they keep looking so particular
even in people who've moved to new
environments or mixed why haven't small
noses become
dominant who says they haven't
i mean it's hardly a rostrum
she's talking this is echo about the
variation within people not compared to
dogs oh oh
why do people with comparatively small
noses not
out compete those with comparatively
large well not even not compete but just
like
you know why why do you end up with
lineage level like
why is a roman nose aroma nose and like
east asian noses and jewish noses and
like
you know there's just there's why is
okay so first of all i would say there's
a lot going on in the nose that we don't
think about
um there is the
recapture of energy that would be lost
to the environment on exhaling and in
fact
if you look at something like walruses
you will find an amazingly
well architected architected counter
current exchange mechanism that
basically
takes heat back from the exhaled air
before it is lost to the environment why
because calories are so
expensive to procure that preserving
them is as good as
as finding them dogs and cats have this
as well um you know in fact when you do
um you know you look at a cat skull uh
and you see you know it's actually at
the skeletal level right and just like
this incredible high surface area to
um volume of the of the bony structures
in the nose that are then covered with
all these sensory
um sensory tissue right and neurological
tissue neurological
and i believe there's going to be some
immunological
function that there's a certain amount
of um perusing the environment for
uh antigens worth knowing about things
like this
um there is uh yeah so anyway i think
i think the basic answer is noses are
doing more than you think it's not just
a snorkel yeah um yeah you can get a
certain amount from that that's the
turbinates i think if um
you can't really see it all that well um
but
because i mean part because it's it's
broken off um
where's my camera um but you can see
some of what looks like spongy stuff
inside the brass room there that's
actually bony otherwise it wouldn't
still be here and this would smell
terrible um so yeah that's that's true
certainly in all the carnivores um i
believe and i
don't know you know like what a mouse
probably in a house too i could actually
have some skulls but
not right here yeah yeah i don't
remember um but in any case i think the
basic answer echo is that
there's a lot going on in the nose it is
sort of underappreciated
how much biological complexity there is
there and there's also stuff like
um it does allow you to go underwater
without having water flood into your
lungs you know
basically by holding a pocket of air
um so in light of all that
you would imagine crocodiles do that
better
they have posteriorly displaced external
nares so they can uh
keep the front part of their nose
underwater and they can still be
breathing yep and they take advantage of
the fact that we're not all that well
structured by it by rolling us
they take advantage of us all the drone
yes that is the nature of crocodiles
um but the point is there are reasons
there are lots there's a lot going on in
the nose
internal areas i misspoke sorry um the
fact of a lot going on in the nose
predicts that you won't basically have
the nose minimized and if the nose isn't
going to be minimized you're going to
get two kinds of variation one of those
kinds of variation is going to be
arbitrary
right some populations just will have
this and some will have that but a lot
of it will also be ecological which is
to say
how much of a danger is heat loss to the
environment
right where it's a greater danger you
will imagine
greater elaboration in response
so anyway basically there's going to be
adaptive and non-adaptive variation you
would expect the non-adaptive variation
to be minimal cost um yeah and i guess
there's a maybe there's a
an assumption at the base of this which
is that large size is more expensive
and i'm not it's not clear and i think
part of what your explanation has been
circling around is uh it's not just
material expense that's the cost
right either in terms of growth or
maintenance but there's also you know
what what kinds of functionality do you
um do you perhaps lose if you have less
for instance sensory surface area inside
your nose
yep and actually there are two ways in
which this works one
is the the only cost is not material
and the other is that you can't
necessarily infer the material cost
in a largely hollow object from the
external dimensions and so we may not be
all that good at guessing how expensive
various different noses are
true
good wow what is going on uh
could
they i think this means we uh could you
have a live discussion with dr pierre
cory a peer-reviewed paper on ivermectin
was published thursday
i would like your input thank you um
i you know i can't remember exactly
which which guy dr pierre corey is
i think he is the guy who's the guy he's
the ivor
guy i looked at his stuff was pretty
impressed by it uh early on
um so anyway i'd like to look at what
was just published
yeah um mary asks actually i'm certain
it was him
okay uh given that intersex is expressed
throughout human history
why should we not include it as a gender
and perhaps aim for this gene question
mark
with adult trans people so i'm not sure
what aim for this
gene and the fact that you have a
question mark i think means that maybe
you're not sure that that's exactly the
right phrasing
either um so intersex is an incredibly
rare and incredibly rare developmental
anomaly
and it has um
developmental and sometimes genetic
right like there are there are i think a
few
ways that it manifests and um trans we
also know has a few
there we actually have a few mechanistic
groups to it there's
like i think i've mentioned before
there's a small population in either
heidi or
um or dominican republic that actually
has a really high rate of trans people
it's actually been traced back to indeed
a genetic variant
but probably most people who are who are
what i call true trans
there isn't anything genetic going on
it's the it's a mismatch that goes on at
some point during development between
the various complex systems that would
normally be
coincident um so i would you know
intersex
isn't a gender intersex is you know not
a not b
in a binary system in which you have
male and female and it's binary and
intersex
is that intermediate which is an
extraordinarily rare
failure well i want to make that more
precise in one way okay
part of the problem the reason it's not
a gender first of all it isn't
synonymous with trans
at all right okay but second thing is
it's not one thing
every case is or i can't say every case
because there may be
cases that fall within a theme but there
are as you point out because there are a
wide
range of ways to get there it's not one
thing
it's not this and not that and that
means you've got a
a bucket of things that are together
by virtue of not being uh in either of
the
traditional modes but i mean really i
mean like just to use the computer
analogy with binary like you know it's
not a one it's not a zero it's a
question mark
yeah or it's missing data or you know
like there's a number of ways to arrive
at like this is a binary system but
sometimes you don't have a one or a zero
right and it doesn't make it not binary
right so i would say that in large
measure
i think the
[Music]
trans ideology has
basically used every place where
something in the neighborhood
of sex and gender is not
simple they've used every element of
gray
to uh create ambiguity
and the whole point is it's the
ambiguity that's doing the heavy lifting
but in this case you know we you know
there is intersex and there is trans
right they're both real but they're not
the same thing
and therefore using one to
you know force something about the other
is just incoherent
yeah our negative racial biases
and stereotypes truly a part of our
unconscious bias and heuristics or are
they subconscious patterns that get
recalled
i think this question requires a real
clear delineation between when
what unconscious and subconscious are
and um
i'm not sure that i
buy that distinction at an absolute
level sufficiently
to therefore be able to answer the
question because i therefore i'm not
sure that i
buy the premise of the question that has
that as the fundamental
distinction yeah uh i will just say
another
another route to addressing i think what
you're getting at
is there is an evolutionary reason
that people should have biases
against people from other populations
and it's very simple which is the
tendency to share genes
with people decreases the farther your
degree of relatedness or the more
distant
your degree of relatedness that is not
an uh condition we can't get over but it
is something we should expect to see
whether it manifests as a belief in
inferiority
or a you know
aggression towards or whatever doesn't
really matter what also doesn't matter
uh or no i won't say it doesn't matter
what is not fundamental is the question
of how that thing
travels and so it can travel entirely in
software
i suspect it does travel mostly if not
entirely in software
and because of that it is relatively
easy to get past it
right you can rewrite the software um
and so anyway i think i think the thing
is don't you don't want to focus too
much
on the mechanism of transmission unless
i mean if the mechanism of transmission
is genetic right if we're wired to
dislike people who don't look like us
then we've got a very serious problem
because
what do you do about genes right we're
not going to crisper a new generation
but there's every indication that that's
not the case right in fact the very
fact of improvement relative to racism
suggests that it is housed in software
and that's good news
i lost where i was here we go
do bright unnatural hair dyes have
anything to do with signaling or faking
toxicity
or is it likely to be subconsciously
interpreted that way what else might be
going on
um i no i think it's actually the
opposite in the case of
of bright hair so the idea of bright
colors
indicating toxicity is something known
as aposmatic coloration
in uh in biology and it happens to be uh
the frogs that i studied both in the new
world the dark poison frogs and the
mantelas in madagascar
are apostomatically colored um and it's
and it's a warning to would be predators
you can see this and you have learned or
somehow know to associate
what this looks like with dangerous to
you
so here is my big warning do not eat um
and this um this almost looks
it it looks like an advertisement but
not
of of toxicity
and i think really i don't want to make
a blanket statement
really but um often of confusion
and people may have an indica a thought
about what it means to them
when they decide to color their hair
some color that is really completely not
anything that ever would be found in
nature
and sometimes it might be um that they
don't feel comfortable in their own skin
and this is uh
this is i don't know why that would be a
response to it or
um they're trying they're they are maybe
trying to keep
um you know attention away from them um
for some
for some young women or i think
unfortunately
increasingly given what we've done to
young people um
people who are growing up and who don't
fit beauty
beauty norms which didn't used to be the
case at such a societal level at such a
population level
may choose to to do things that render
them even
farther outside of the usual beauty
norms
and i think if you asked them mostly
whatever answer they gave you would not
necessarily be the thing that is
actually true about why they made that
decision
took me a long time through your
excellent
response to that question to understand
what the question was really getting at
um like we're talking about
blue hair for example yeah oh yeah i
just did not
didn't even occur to me until i think so
bright and natural hair dyes that's how
i read that
yep well see i read i don't know why i
read it this way but i read it as
unnatural to the person so somebody
choosing to dye their hair red or
blonde or something like that um
yeah now i get it um so yeah i would i
would say
uh i'm sure it's not one thing
but um i think you know people
show up in the world in ways that they
perceive
cause people to treat them more the way
they want to be treated and so
it could be standoffish it could be
designed
to take you out of a known category so
people
i don't know are open to finding out
that you're different than
they would guess or something like that
don't know but yeah
but i mean it also it certainly
contributes to
the division and the anger now um that
um increasingly you know it's it's it's
a star
on a sneach for people both in the group
and outside of the group
and um it would be you know i
personally i don't think it's safe i
don't think that you know the dyes and
hair dyes are not are not safe and so
um i think it's ill-advised to
color your hair even if it looks like a
color that you could have had
um that said
uh this seems to me to now be being used
to just further
deepen the rifts between us yeah and
markers of in-group
yeah markers of tribe and um
you know in general i think markers of
tribe are
something that is what a lot of
adolescents is about
trying on um but really best
if they can be temporary uh and you can
you can shed them later and you can um
you don't have a permanent marker of
that tribal affinity
on social media or something that you
have to constantly live with because
someone screen captured it
um so you know playing around with
identity is a
real and necessary and enduring and
permanent part of
of the human experience but we all
deserve the right to you know get beyond
it and then not have these permanent
markers of identity
um that we chose when we're babies
effectively um sticking with us
yep totally agree
um i always forget how to pronounce this
university
um in 1988 campus protests at is it
gaiadet or gallaudet
gallaudet okay so um in 1988 campus
protests at gallaudet
university are remembered as deaf
president now
if you are familiar would you share your
perspective i didn't i did not know that
um so gallaudet is is is the university
for
um for deaf students i'm sure that that
description would be
taken as offensive but basically that's
that's right no i'm not so sure
um so i think the protest
was to get a deaf president of gallaudet
that sounds like it yeah yeah i think
that's what i don't
that's that's all i know well you could
imagine that they were demanding a deaf
president of
you know the country but no i think this
is about
i mean i don't think so we've certainly
had our share of tone deaf presidents
especially of late
but in this case yeah i mean
you know we're in a tough spot because
the fact of
a college for the deaf that is not led
by a member of the deaf community
has got to be a bit alienating on the
other hand
what is the purpose of a college
president and you know to the extent
that we speak as insiders because we
have been
you know at colleges the college
president is in part
an outward facing entity right
and so what i would say is
there's a trade-off and are you better
off as a deaf college to have a deaf
president
or are you better off as a deaf college
to have somebody who
deeply understands the plight of the
deaf and is in a position
to speak on their behalf to those who
are not deaf
and i don't know i have no idea no i
don't know either i imagine
that there have been you know of course
these conversations will have happened
at hbcus as well historically black
colleges and universities
um and i i guess i assume that most of
those
have had a black president yeah um
but i don't actually know and um but in
that case i think it's easier
i mean in fact i think it's probably
easy okay in the sense
that there's no um
there's no reason there are plenty of
black people who can inhabit that job
and yes it will not it's a big enough
pool that you're that yeah
right it's not a tiny pool and it's not
well but it's not a it's also not
an obstacle to you know deafness
is unfortunately an obstacle to
communication and so to the extent that
this is
communicating to the outside world i'm
totally with you on the second reason
right like deafness is actually
a handicap yes i used that word right um
and blackness shouldn't be you know to
the degree that it has been
it's imposed yep right um societally
um but you know the argument in general
against saying okay we want someone of
this demographic is no matter how giant
that demographic is
even if the demographic is 90 of the
population like you know okay let's you
know
90 like we need a right-hander for this
job well what if the right person
happens to be a left-hander
right you mean yes obviously the
candidate pool for presidents of
historically black colleges and
universities if you're only looking at
black people is going to be
quite large but it's still smaller than
if you were in
if you were looking at everyone well i
agree i mean you know if we were talking
about
uh you know something where the skill
set
you know if you're looking for a surgeon
you want the best person no matter what
color they are
right um if you're looking for somebody
who's the head of a black
college then their insight into
being black is presumably an asset that
you know it's not to say you couldn't
have a more qualified candidate
who isn't going to be black but i find
the likelihood of it pretty low
right because part of part of what the
college is about is about addressing
that experience
well and i mean i i guess you know that
argument can be applied
to uh these protests that i wasn't aware
of in 1988
right right except that there's a
disadvantage that comes comes with it
which is
well there's two right that it's an
actual handicap
and um it's such a tiny proportion of
the population
yeah but i guess i guess what i would
say is i'm pretty sure
you know there's always a question about
whether students
are really in a position to decide who
ought to be
in charge of the college because they
are there inherently temporarily
right but if gallaudet you know
i think the population of gallaudet is
probably in a pretty good position to
know whether their interests are better
represented by somebody who understands
their
experience more directly by virtue of
being deaf or somebody who's in a better
position
to interface with the non-deaf world
well but i feel like you just delighted
like you said
there's always a question about whether
or not students should be in a position
and then you said the population so what
do you mean by the population
well what i would hope and frankly i
don't know
i would imagine but maybe i'm just wrong
um that uh gallaudet is you know
taught by a mostly deaf faculty do we
have any idea whether that's likely to
be true i don't know
um so if that's true then the faculty or
faculty and staff or faculty and
academic staff
people who are there permanently but you
know what you would hope ideally what
you want is
students in consultation with the
effectively the permanent population
well and that's you know that's what
we've seen at
you know the universities that we've
seen up close and personal with regard
to some of the administrative
stuff and like who gets to sit on who
gets to
who is enjoined to sit on things like
hiring committees who cannot avoid
sitting on hiring committees yes um
and other committees um almost always
in uh i i feel like i remember at
at three universities where i've run
colleges where i've managed to see it
or be part of it um there's a
there's a student representative um such
that the student
can you know is unlikely to be you know
the person who makes the decision but
they could be the deciding vote in
something
um and uh in general you know
for i feel like i've seen this i saw
this at uc santa cruz as well
but i know for sure that i you know i
was on comm i was on committees as a
student at university of michigan
and i was on committees as faculty at
evergreen and
um in many of those committees um
obviously when i was a student there was
a student because it was me
and um at evergreen they were often
students
and they were you know carefully chosen
and it wasn't a mob
and it wasn't all students and it wasn't
a democratic vote so that because
students outnumber everyone else they
therefore get what they want
but students do deserve voice just not
um
you know proportional to their numbers
yeah
um where are we at zack there are a lot
of questions
okay um i'm gonna let's try to get
through like four more because we have a
ton of questions this hour
all right um and we're going to miss
most of them apologies
did either of you get vaccinated if so
which one
not yet yep not yet i imagine we will be
forced to it eventually but um
frankly you know as we said early on
the more time there is the more you know
about the risks and frankly this week
we're finding out that the spike protein
itself may
do damage to the body at a significant
level that's certainly something you
would want to know
um so yeah you know it's
it's so you know one of the other things
about that paper which it looks like
over
over the break someone actually sent it
and said that there was a reason that it
hadn't been available so
it looks like we have access to it now
um but that paper out of um
who was it um who did it
salk institute right um yep
uh
i lost it we're talking about the uh
wanting to know the spike protein
let's go on okay given estimates that as
many as 80
of species are still undiscovered does
that leave room for bigfoot
loch ness and other monsters
uh no
no um well you know i mean monsters it
depends on what you mean by monsters
neither of those particular monsters but
yeah
let's put it this way those numbers
about the number of species that are
undiscovered are both interesting and
not as interesting as you might think
because
of what those species likely are in many
of those cases probably the vast
majority of them
they are minor variants on things that
are known
right so there will be lots of fungal
species we're not particularly good at
sorting out well
they're also going to be just a ton of
single celled right
there's going to be single-celled things
it's going to be very rare to discover a
new mammal
fungi right there's going to be lots of
insects that we don't know but they're
not going to be you know it's
there's a question of how big a clade
some new thing that you find
actually represents and in general these
are going to be species and clades we
know
um so in general we are not talking
about large creatures now every so often
some
interesting new mammal pops up in
vietnam or some place
um this happens but
you know they don't tend to be gigantic
they tend to be
you know it'd be really interesting to
find something that size that happens
every decade or so
there was a new primate within the last
decade or two
but it wasn't super surprised like it
wasn't like
whoa what is that it was a yeah we
actually think that's new we're going to
call it a different species from this
other species to which it is clearly
sister
right right so that happens the big
charismatic stuff well it wasn't
splitting it wasn't like we already know
this is the case and now we've created a
new species it's like no
there's discovery of a new a new morph
of a thing
yeah and i was like yeah this is new but
it's clearly closely related to that
that wasn't a
in the lat you know in you know over in
systematic space splitting this is a
discovery
um but that that is going to be how the
that's going to be with the new species
discoveries of the charismatic megafauna
and i would say that um bigfoot or loch
ness
definitely would qualify as charismatic
megafauna yes
now the deep ocean could harbor some
stuff
yeah that's why i said it depends on
what you mean by monsters there might be
monsters
in the deep ocean yeah there can be
although chances that we've never seen a
carcass or
yeah that's from a sub or something like
that is low
there's weird stuff i remember a long
time ago
uh back when i was at penn as an early
undergraduate
a discussion of gigantopithecus
which was known from teeth where we
actually had the teeth but we didn't
have the rest of the creature
probably this is almost certain this is
an extinct creature but
um you know one that
has existed until late enough that there
would be um
teeth on the surface uh sub fossil stuff
so i don't know yeah i think i think i
wouldn't be betting on bigfoot
um it's pretty hard to imagine that it
would have anywhere to go
that we would not be happening on it
with some regularity
um and of course there was a lot of hoax
stuff you know people who had
feet manufactured that they walked
around to leave the impression of a big
foot
um interestingly i have not told you of
course that happened but
um toby is very hard to photograph and i
was when we were out for your birthday
photographing
him trying to capture the actual
creature as he exists in the wild
not a simple job but i did get a
sequence that is
almost exactly like that famous sequence
of bigfoot you know the walking
the three or four frames walking out of
the forest
is he equally out of focus this bigfoot
is in that sequence he is in somewhat
better focus nothing nothing less of you
yes
oh i should show you some of the out of
focus stuff because uh
this new camera as far as it uh it
creates a
it's so high resolution that you can
tell that almost everything is out of
focus
almost all the time
all right um any thoughts on if or how
much
long covid could be placebo or side
effect of being locked inside and
socially isolated for long periods of
time
i guess i would add to your list of
possibilities is that it's exacerbated
by
so placebo is one possibility um a side
effect
that is like largely caused by
um locked inside and socially isolated
um
or there's something real maybe
autoimmune which is what we've both
thought
um that is you know perhaps wildly
exacerbated by um the social stuff
that's going on
and the lack of activity and the lack of
sunlight and
everything else yeah i i will say it is
certain i would say given the vagaries
of physiology and the complexity of it
that some fraction of those who think
they have
long covered either have something
psychosomatic
or uh have something else that was just
coincident in time
but my guess having spent a lot of time
on the
long-haul covid subreddit is that
there's an awful lot of long-haul cove
that's just simply real very mysterious
and medicine has a bias where it doesn't
like dealing with things it doesn't
understand anything about and so it
tends to be dismissive and it was for
too long
but anyway the um so
there are many things in play that could
be doing this
one of them is the
arms race between virus and
immune system leaves
so if you'll remember my explanation of
how the immune system
works it evolves towards solutions to
pathogens
it also has holes so that you don't
respond to your own tissues and that
means that
the extent that any pathogen resembles
your own tissue it has an advantage
because it can hide from the immune
system in the holes in the immune system
that are reserved for self
and so there is every opportunity here
for autoimmunity
to evolve there is every opportunity for
um spike protein
and possible antibodies two spike
proteins so there are things called
anti-antibodies
so anyway there's lots of things that
could be inducing this and
the fact that some of it will inherently
be
a psychosomatic should not cause us to
dismiss the phenomenon as as that it
really doesn't look like it and
you know we're talking about something
super complex yeah
okay next um
are there any studies supporting
asymptomatic spread
is there any real evidence of this and
then the next the
third part of this question i don't
quite understand
um by cdc one-third of 2020 excess
deaths are not
covered what the [ __ ]
so i don't know i'm not aware of what
that is in reference to
or to what the cdc might attribute uh
excess deaths that are you know a third
a third of the excess deaths from 2020
uh if not
if not coveted with regard to the
studies uh
supporting asymptomatic spread uh while
you were talking just now brett i went
and
and looked and it was episode i can't
find it again
this computer um episode 60
what was it episode 63
where we talked about a paper that came
out this year
johansen at all sars covey ii
transmission
from people without covet 19 symptoms um
and that was uh that was mid-january
of this year that we talked about that
paper and really i
found that it was a terrible paper and
did not provide the evidence for
asymptomatic spread
that the authors of the paper imagined
or claimed that it did um that said i
have not
gone and searched explicitly
on asymptomatic spread papers since then
um
i seem to you know collect a fair number
of code papers um but it's possible that
something came out that i haven't seen
although i doubt it
um therefore um the answer to the
question
is i don't really think so um
that there is certainly asymptomatic
spread
but the idea that it's super super
common um
is largely when i've when i have seen it
that claim made in the media it largely
traces back to that one paper
um that i feel like i pretty much
debunked back in january
well um so let's separate between
asymptomatic spread and pre-symptomatic
spread 100 percent not the same thing at
all
right really not this is definitely
pre-symptomatic spread for sure
and um and that and that actually that
paper
um did try did point out the distinction
but then
couldn't delineate between them in some
cases yeah
and there's also the question about how
the vaccine which does seem to reduce
symptoms in people who get the vaccine
and then get sick
does it increase the likelihood of
asymptomatic spread or
does it reduce sickness and spread and
and
so anyway it's a question but i mean i
think
i'm not saying it we know it happens
some yep
i don't think it ha i see no reason to
suspect that it happens as much as that
paper said it did because
the data that that paper was relying on
were did not say what even it said they
did
yeah um so that leaves us with the
question of
how much is it how common like how
common is it and i don't know i have not
seen any evidence
yeah i don't know either i i certainly
leave open the possibility
this is a weird enough disease that uh
it may be doing something very different
but um
i wouldn't leap to conclusions either
way yeah
um i'm gonna just find one more fun
question to end on
fun well i'll try all right um
i'll try um
no it's just gonna take me um
too long so i will um there are three
questions two from the last hour that um
are from poland so i'm just gonna i
think two of them are just comments so
i'm just gonna read the three poland
questions from poland because it's a
geographic connection and that gets us
through a few
more let's see where were we um
i lost one of them okay there's just two
hey i don't even listen to super chat
section but greetings from poland folks
you keep me entertained and educated
every saturday night
great job um oh and the other one that i
thought was from
poland was from portland all right
apparently can't read
thanks for keeping a level head through
these times keep up the good work
weinstein family much love from portland
love that uh and love this person says
the green mini in the back
yes which we built with my mother as she
has
it's not green but she has a mini she
has a mini yeah yes which suits her well
yes it does
um okay final final question poland
bouncy we're back to poland now
we're back not portland poland um poland
banned woke ideology in schools
in the u.s it is engraved in schools and
companies
identity politics is increasing is this
reversible
when did it start well that's a giant
question yes
i'm betting giant question poland will
become more powerful by virtue of the
fact that its people can still think
yeah yeah that's a that's a crazy
prediction
yeah it's really out there yeah it's
wild but um yeah
i i don't know i mean i'm of course
troubled by the idea of
banning stuff because once you step on
that slippery slope where does it go but
certainly keeping wokeness out of your
schools is a great
idea and i really wish we were doing
that because
you know you never know they've uh
kids could turn out to be the future
kids could turn out to be the future
yeah
um when did there are a lot of different
time scale answers to when did it start
and i think two of them i think there's
something much deeper in time that i
don't have a grasp on yet um
but the two time periods that i point to
um most in terms of helping to create
this
this the ascendancy of the world
cardiology are sort of the rise
of um postmodernism in academia in the
80s and 90s
actually when we were in college and
then it kind of disappeared
it was it was always in these like niche
fields the problem was that some of
those students who were studying it went
on to become
academics themselves and they've taken
over departments and created whole new
fields and they're just you know
on on the rise so that's one sort of
from
uh 30ish years ago and then the second
of course is this perfect storm that
we've talked about a lot and that
um greg lukianov and jonathan height
talk about in their book the coddling of
the american mind
of um of the screens
and actually i'm not sure that they talk
about i don't remember which of these
things they all talk about um they
definitely talk about the bad parenting
in terms of helicopter parenting and
snowplow parenting
uh the rise of screens and to some
degree what's on them but
we talk specifically about just the
danger of the screens themselves the
interactions with the screens
and then the pharmaceutical drugs for
mood disorders both real and imagined
um that came together in in such that by
2013 or so
is the date that they propose and that
is a match for our anecdotal experience
and that of many other people whom we
have talked to
increasingly the students who were
meeting in college classrooms
had a different error about them that
um it was it was it was different and
that then was a match for students
who had been you know raised in this
toxic
stew going to college and in some cases
depending on what classes they chose to
take
meeting nothing but post-modern idiocy
in the classroom
and like i said i think there's
something that goes farther back in time
than that that starts farther back in
time than that
and there are of course you know roots
of this and shades of it
and variations in various political
ideologies
all of that is true but this particular
like how do we get to this particular
spot
those are two of the more recent things
but there's there's something deeper as
well and i don't
i don't really have a fix on it i would
just add i think they're
you know if you have a fringe
viewpoint you also perceive that
you can't wield power and
the coddling of these viewpoints inside
of universities
created a kind of an incubator where the
ideas developed but they didn't have the
power to take over and then there was a
demographic shift
which may have to do with the
characteristics that
uh that hyde and lukiana point to that
came together but something caused a
recognition that actually now they had
enough power to start wielding
um and to have effects and so there's
just whatever threshold was crossed
where you detect
that we are now in a position to make
things happen and i think that that
happened in the last
few years yeah
i think that's right um
i think we're done i think we are there
i think we are there
yes so please consider joining us
at one or both of our patreons subscribe
to the channel
subscribe to the clips channel uh like
tell your friends share on um
whatever whatever modes you feel like
sharing
with people whom you think might be
interested um
yeah yes um
[Music]
okay i'll finish up go outside
be good to the people you love and eat
good food and go outside
all right we'll see you soon